dans un épisode précédent vous avez
parlé de la difficulté que j'ai à
contrôler mon utilisation des réseaux
sociaux puisque ils sont intenses a
utilisé de façon un peu un peu a dit
yves faire ce qu'on appelle parfois du
tarn scrolling scrollé sans fin et sans
but et je sens que tout ça c'est en fait
extrêmement nocif
non seulement à mon bien-être mais aussi
à ma capacité d'attention de réflexion
et même de bienveillance et donc je
pense que c'est assez important qu'on
réfléchisse cas c'était super important
pour moi que je réfléchisse davantage à
comment mieux utiliser mon téléphone et
éviter ces phénomènes d'addiction et en
particulier au cours de ces dernières
années
bah j'ai identifié quelques astuces donc
je vais partager avec vous cette astuce
que j'ai trouvé pour mieux consommer les
réseaux sociaux
la première astuce qui va plus simple à
implémenter qui a le plus d'effet c'est
simplement d'enlever les notifications
pour aller dans les réglages de votre
appareil et interdire par exemple les
notifications twitter facebook youtube
et tout ça c'est qu'ils étaient youtuber
qui vous disent de mettre la cloche pour
avoir des notifications sur votre
téléphone
mais je pense que c'est quelque chose
d'assez mal en fait en général parce que
ça a tendance à interrompre notre
attention
il ya pas mal de recherches très
préoccupante sur notre capacité
d'attention et qui montrent que cette
attention énormément décru au cours des
dernières années notre façon de mesurer
l'importance d'enlever céline
notification se rendent compte que
lorsque vous recevez une notification de
certains manière c'est votre téléphone
qui vous dit ce que vous allez faire et
vous ce que vous devez faire ce que vous
devez payer intention de prêter
attention
et au lieu de ça je pense que c'est
beaucoup plus sain d'avoir une approche
proactive par rapport à votre téléphone
au lieu de vous laisser dire quand est
ce qu'il faut que vous allez sur les
réseaux sociaux
l'idée c'est d'aller sur les asociaux
uniquement quand vous décidez quand vous
voulez consciemment aller sur ces
réseaux sociaux
la deuxième astuces pour améliorer nos
relations avec nos réseaux sociaux c'est
de masquer tous les contenus que qu'elle
vous ne voulez pas être exposés parce
qu'ils sont nocifs y sommes trop
virulents sont trop violents ou parce
que c'est des sujets qui sont trop
anxiogène pardon dans une période donnée
et à ce moment là ça peut être utile de
masquer les comptes qui parle trop de
cela c'est pas parce que ces comptes
mauvais ou autres sauces et jusque sont
pas ce à quoi vous pensez qu'il est
préférable que vous soyez exposé
typiquement tuteur en particulier vous
donne aussi l'option de masquer tous les
tweets qui consiste comme ils
contiennent un mot donné nous par
exemple - mon tuteur sur twitter le leem
au maquereau et être un peu son son
masque et c'est à dire que tous les
tuteurs qui parle de train ou de mâcon
centre sont masquées de base et ne me
sont pas recommandés et si jamais j'ai
envie de m'informer au sujet de ces de
ces personnes j'irai de moi même mais
pas en étant exposés par les réseaux
sociaux en profite aussi pour ajouter
que je pense que c'est bien puisque
préférable de masquer les gens plutôt
que de les bloquer parce que bloquer les
personnes passées c'est un axe très
virulent puisque vous signaler à l'autre
notamment le fait que vous ne voulez pas
d'elle et ça peut créer des tensions qui
au final font que vous serez quand même
exposé indirectement via d'autres
comptes au message de ce que vous ne
voulez pas suivre c'est pour ça que je
pense que au moins dans certains cas il
est préférable de masquer plutôt que
deux blocs une troisième mesure qui m'a
été extrêmement meilleur indispensable
ça ça va vraiment révolutionné ma
relation avec mon téléphone c'est
d'installer des applications qui
m'interdisent d'aller sur les réseaux
sociaux
donc j'ai utilisé une app qui s'appelle
of time voit ses plantations de produits
c'est ce qui rend une app qui a
énormément amélioré
mon état de santé mentale donc je suis
avec plaisir que le culot recommande aux
tags je sais qu'il y en a d'autres plus
chercher applications pour pour bloquer
les réseaux sociaux et moi
personnellement je en ce moment cette
éducation est lancé tous les jours
toutes les nuits plutôt entre 9h30 et
nouveaux amis de 21h30 à 9h30 c'est un
peu mon couvre-feu finalement des
réseaux sociaux et ça me fait énormément
de bien parce que je sais que moins
d'aller se coucher c'est là le plus
grand piège parce que c'est là que je
suis plus fatigué je suis le plus
vulnérable à l'addiction aux réseaux
sociaux
et donc c'est là que j'ai le plus besoin
que l'on coupé la source
et cette application of time le fait
très très bien pareil au réveil ça
permet de se forcer à ne pas penser aux
réseaux sociaux
et pour moi personnellement ça va faire
un bien fou or dans le même ordre
d'idées une autre mesure que j'ai prise
c'est essayer d'aller aux années autant
que possible les réseaux sociaux par an
sur mon téléphone ne surtout pas les
mettre sur la page d'accueil donc pour
pouvoir accéder à twitter je suis obligé
de faire au moins trois clics
ça rend l'application un peu plus
éloignés donc ça évite zombies les deux
clics et par accident ou pas sur ses
applications
[Applaudissements]
quatrième mesure également extrêmement
importante que j'ai faite c'est de
prendre le contrôle des ja de
recommandations donc ses algorithmes qui
vont suggérer du contenu et faire que
telle vidéo me fera suggéré et l autre
ne le sera pas en fait ces algorithmes
vous pouvez les les contrôles et les
manipuler haut lieu on manipule soit sur
facebook twitter ou youtube
badia effet de s'abonner à certains
comptes plutôt que d'autres mais il ya
aussi le fait lorsque vous voyez une
vidéo par exemple vous pouvez donc sur
un petit onglet à droite sur lequel vous
pouvez cliquer demandé à youtube de ne
plus vous recommander cette vidéo si
c'est une vidéo laquelle vous ne
souhaitez pas être exposés pareil pour
les tweets et pareil pour les les
messages facebook et ça ça complètement
révolutionné ma relation à youtube
puisque maintenant lorsque vous êtes sur
youtube essentiellement youtube me force
à voir des vidéos de maths et ses
patrouilles de rock samba samba parce
que mon du coup quand je suis fatigué ça
me donne une bonne raison de deux kits
et youtube alors jeu comme une astuce
parce que j'ai quand même envie de
regarder des vidéos de foot notamment
sur youtube et du coup une astuce c'est
d'ouvrir ses vidéos dans des onglets en
navigation privée
sur la plupart des navigateurs vous
pouvez avoir ça et du coup je peux
toujours accéder à ces vidéos et je crée
des anges c'est de me relâcher en
regardant ces vidéos mais du coup enfin
c'est un effort supplémentaire et
surtout ce sera pas dans mon historique
ce qui fait que youtube ne me
recommandera pas ces vidéos la prochaine
fois que j'irai sur youtube et ça c'est
extrêmement utile pour votre addiction
une cinquième mesure c'est de faire
beaucoup plus attention à tout ce que
j'écris tout ce que je like et tout ce
que je partage sur les réseaux sociaux
est même allé plus loin que ça en me
forçant à recommander des contenus que
je trouve particulièrement bon ou qui
ont une idée particulièrement
intéressante surtout quand c'est quelque
chose qui ne vient pas de mon groupe
j'essaie de me dissocier de tout groupe
qui soit mais quand ça vient de quelque
chose d'autre que monsieur fillon va
dire ça me fait encore une motivation
supplémentaire pour partager ce contenu
et donc je pense que c'est un bon
réflexe à avoir pour s'habituer à penser
un peu un peu différemment et surtout
avoir le bon côté dans tout ce que tout
le monde fait également reconnaissante à
la santé mentale ça permet dur de mettre
en avant davantage quelque chose qui est
positif plutôt que toujours se plaindre
et là je vous renvoie vers la vidéo
précédente que j'ai fait sur le livre
you what you read de joe jackson qui
suggère très très très fortement que ce
que vous partagez ce coup là qu'est au
quotidien un effet sur votre bien-être
mental et aussi votre vision du monde et
si tout est très négatif est partie que
les choses négatives
il faut s'attendre à voir aussi un biais
de négativité qui en plus d'être mal
bien au point de vue
santé mentale me donnait des visions 13
erronée du monde renvoie aux vidéos de
hans rosling qui sont fascinantes à ce
sujet 6e mesure que j'ai mis de plus en
plus en pratique un peu plus récemment
c'est de constamment cherché à envoyer
des messages privés toute bonne excuse
pour envoyer un message privé et ben
j'ai envie de dire donc à chaque fois
que je pense à quelqu'un même si c'est
pour une raison stupide
ouais je vais envoyer un message et dans
ma tête je pensais à tout ça et ça ça
que ça crée des relations beaucoup plus
humaine à travers à travers internet et
surtout dans les périodes de confinement
je pense que c'est extrêmement important
de garder ce lien donc toutes les bonnes
excuses pour recréer du lien je pense
sont les bonnes et les réseaux sociaux
sont pas forcément le bon endroit pour
le faire tous les réseaux sociaux
publics ou ou assez peu privé on va dire
ce que j ai pour les messages
bienveillants s'applique également pour
les critiques je pense que des critiques
qui se font en privé basse a beaucoup
plus de chance de mieux se passer de
conduire des choses plus positives que
balancer un truc comme ça sur la sphère
publique tout sur twitter qu on dire par
défaut au moins commencer par les
critiques en privé si jamais ça va pas
on peut réfléchir à d'autres solutions
et moi je pense que commencer en privé
c'est ça c'est quand même quelque chose
de plus humain et qu'il ya plus de
chance de mieux c'est terminé
enfin la septième et dernière mesure
donc ses intrigues e reich une plaine
j'en ai parlé dans une autre vidéo de
cette série donc un trigger actionne
plein c'est lorsque à chaque fois vous
remarqué que vous faites quelque chose
il devait prendre une certaine action et
vous devez répéter tout ça pour
apprendre l'habitude de déclencher cette
action à chaque fois que vous avez le
trigger le truc qui déclenche qui est
censé d'enclencher les actions et donc
le trigger actionne planckeel je pense
assez c'est celui que je vais appeler
maintenant le trigger actionne plein du
doom scrolling parce que j'ai découvert
le modem scrolling récemment est choqué
c'est un mot extrêmement pertinents doug
string c'est quoi c'est le fait de
scrollé wade d'être sur votre téléphone
ou sur votre ordinateur et 2 constamment
recharger les mêmes pages ou scr orléans
battu peter pour voir des nouveaux
tweets ou à voir quelles sont les
nouvelles vidéos sur youtube
quels sont les nouveaux posts sur
facebook et il ya les toits sont un peu
mécanique comme ça sans savoir ce que
l'on cherche et sans avoir cet ennui ou
d'un moment on a vu dit 8 ou 5 38 bon a
priori on sait moment de passer à autre
chose 31e a peu de chances d'être
vraiment intéressant et est en fait
c'est vraiment ces moments là où
l'addiction et la pire ces séances et
moment où on est dans le leur à
vitrolles add on sait qu'on est vraiment
dans cet engrenage et qui le plus
difficile en sortir et c'est aussi là
pour risque d'être le plus fatigué le
plus énervé et d'être le moins
bienveillants et donc c'est super
important de sortir de ce genre de
phases nous semble super important de
sortir genre de phase dès que possible
et du coup on tape du doom scrolling
j'avais déjà parlé en fait dans la vidéo
une vidéo précédente
c'est simplement le fait que dès que je
me dis à mme autodiagnostic à avoir
ouvert
tu t'es art typiquement ou une page
comme ça sans faire exprès ou ce que je
sens que je perds un peu le contrôle de
ce que je fais et ça arrive très très
soulagé c'est d'éloigner le téléphone lg
c'est d'éloigner l'ordinateur je veux
faire mon ordinateur j'ai enfin le
téléphone même si j'étais en train de
travailler car en gt pas en train de
bien travailler c'est le moment de faire
une pause de prendre une tisane
de lire un livre ou de lire un article
de se mettre à lire un truc plus long et
si si vraiment ça marche pas bien nous
demande de sortir de chez soi c'est un
peu con qui vieillit en perdre de
couvre-feu de confinement qu'on n'ait
pas à faire un autre confidence qu'il
faut quand même envisager que ça se sera
pas disponible mais du coup essayer de
s'organiser des activités qui seront
aussi éloignée du téléphone que possible
faire un jeu de société avec des amis ou
autres s'y essayer de se détacher du
mode dans le dôme scrolling autant que
possible des cons ce diagnostic
soto diagnostic en mode zoom scrolling
donc là c'était mais cette astuce pour
mieux consommer les réseaux sociaux et
je veux dire qu' il soit insuffisant en
tout cas pour moi c'est à dire que après
maintenant pas mal de temps à voir a
essayé d'appliquer ces règles bah je
m'en rends compte que j'ai toujours
surprendre l'addiction que je vais
toujours sur twitter et quand ce n'est
pas sur mon téléphone c'est sur
ordinateur et j'ai passé ça reste
difficile
je pense que ça a beaucoup beaucoup aidé
donc voilà le camp de m
mais clairement il en faut plus me faut
de meilleures idées et si vous avez des
idées n'hésitez pas à les partager aussi
en commentaire ça peut être intéressant
pour tous